hey welcome to the monitor that's for
you and pointing at you because you're
watching it as always I am Peter Ruben
sit senior editor at Wired they keep
doing that one of these days we'll get
it straightened out at any rate we are
getting ready for comic-con I'm actually
there right now but the magic of
television means that I tape this first
but for the show we're actually gonna
get ready for comic-con the place where
I am right now not right here but right
now and pick for your DVR but first
we're going to talk about what I am just
I'm just going to call it it's over it's
the album of the year and that is Frank
Ocean channel orange which actually
comes out next week we're talking about
it now because the comic-con stuff is
happening and it's let me get out ahead
of this one so Frank Ocean
singer-songwriter R&B guy put out this
incredible free album / mixtape last
year called nostalgia ultra which if you
have not heard it please go get that
this is his major late major label debut
it's on def jam and it's hard to believe
this is this kid's first actual album
he's 24 but he's incredibly self-assured
and he makes our be only makes soul
music is what he makes and it dabbles in
a lot of different sounds but it is as
fantastic as nostalgia ultra was though
there's a little more money behind it
but it's still kind of a journey of one
guy through the world of love and
heartbreak and has just his lyricism is
it is difficult to put in the word
speaking on the fly how talented this
kid is but it is out next week and and
you really need to buy this album this
is if it's definitely in the top three
of what I've heard so far this year and
and I can't see anything coming out
later this year that I'm nearly as
excited about as I am for this and as I
have for everyone to hear this so that's
channel orange by Frank Ocean grab it
but now we're going to talk about some
comic books because that's also what we
do on the monitor hello does this look
like I have mental powers beyond most
mortals it should though I don't because
the comic book this week is Harbinger on
on valiant yes
valiant of all places smaller comic
press it is written by joshua dysart
with art by qari evans and it is the
tale of a youngish man a teenaged man
also named Peter though I swear that's
not the only reason that I liked it a
teenager named Peter with mental
abilities I can only arch this eyebrow
so even though I'm going from this hand
to this hand I'm not going to change
eyebrows mental abilities telekinesis MK
ULTRA style mind control looks like
martial arts but that's not what he does
though he probably could with his mind
at any rate it is the beginning of a
long saga about his discovery by another
man with similar powers and you get the
sense that these are people who have
lived and done their craft over decades
centuries perhaps even millennia and
Peter's decision in the first issue
whether kind of witch attack to take
which path to go on is he going to join
these people is he gonna stay on the lam
where he's being pursued by possible
government agencies we don't really know
for sure we just know that there's a lot
of stuff that's going on and we're going
to sort it all out in future issues I
always love coming in on series at issue
one and i also love giving a little
shine to the presses that aren't as much
at the forefront always talking about DC
and Marvel and pop count idw an image
and dark horse but valiant promising
little title there let's give it a shot
Harbinger pick it up back to you okay
thanks for that there's obviously way
more comic stuff to come that's just a
taste so let's talk about TV and in
particular let's talk about show time
for a second because last year they
they've had some good shows in the past
few years weeds and nurse jackie and
some people like Californication I don't
some do last year two shows came that in
my opinion were just great one was
homeland which is incredible in season
two is going to be coming in late
September but the other one that a lot
of people didn't hear about was a show
called episodes which was about to
British sitcom writers who come to the
states to make a pilot of
US version of their award-winning
british show and the trials and travails
of having your creative soul sucked out
of you and spat on the ground basically
so it is back and also notably it
co-stars matt LeBlanc AKA joey from
friends AKA joey from joey short-lived
friends spin-off on NBC let's not talk
about that though but the show which
picks up in season two with the pilot
being picked up I don't want to spoil
things if you haven't seen season 1 but
the the sitcom riders the british couple
stephen mangan and tamsin greig are both
well they're very British and so it
what's nice about it is for those of you
who like BBC comedies it actually brings
a nice note of that though it's the fish
out of water thing and it puts them in
the soulless void that is la's
entertainment industry so if you are
like me and you enjoy satirizing the
process of basically having your
creativity absolutely vissa rated and
having your dreams torn out of your
chest and also your hope and your faith
in all things creative then you will
enjoy this as much as I do but that's
that and that's it for the monitor but
actually it's Thursday now we're going
to be coming from to you I'm going to be
coming to you from San Diego from the
floor of comic-con itself as soon as we
can we have some great stuff planned
over the next few days some things we're
going to cover some things are going to
talk to you about some people we are
going to talk with for your benefit but
until then email us at the monitor at
wire calm and let us know what's going
to be a comic con that you want us to be
talking about for your enjoyment but
until then inspirational catchphrase
here
you